normalerweise gleich der größten
flughafen in nairobi am morgen einem
bienenstock
die bush flieger mit den safari
urlaubern stammen aus dass afrika
abenteuer in den nationalparks ruft
durch die korona krise steht seit wochen
fast alles still
nur der propeller von peter bulheller
dreht sich als journalisten darf uns der
deutsche besitzer in die berühmte masai
mara fliegen internationale besucher
fehlanzeige in diesen tagen peter
mülheim die ganze tourismusbranche
kenias steht unter schock
[Musik]
eine noch nie da gewesene situation sei
das für menschen aber auch für die tiere
sagt der 58 jährige
die genießen die ruhe auf den lehrern
rollbahnen zwei landeanflüge müssen wir
abbrechen erst sind antilopen zebras auf
der piste beim dritten mal klappt es
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die tiere haben etwas platz gemacht
jetzt sind sie alt so gebunden dass er
niemand ist es ist schon über acht
wochen so dass die da jetzt besitz
ergriffen haben und jetzt da gar nicht
mehr den ersten verlassen wollen auch
wenn ein pfleger ankommt schon kurz nach
der landung übernehmen giraffen wieder
die kontrolle magische masai mara der
klang des berühmten tierschutzgebiet es
allein ruft schon sehnsüchte hervor und
zehntausende touristen aus der ganzen
welt folgen in normalen jahren diesem
ruf nun aber kein geländewagen weit und
breit hier an der grenze zwischen kenia
und tansania
die luxus camps und safari zelte in der
masai mara völlig verwaist
selbst während schwerer politischer
krisen und nach tödlichen
terroranschlägen kamen wenigstens ein
paar gäste sagt peter bellheim in den
90er jahren quittierte er seinen job an
der deutschen botschaft in kenia um sich
mit dem safari unternehmen sein afrika
traum zu erfüllen
nun ist sein lebenswerk bedroht viele
seiner mitarbeiter sind schon seit
jahren bei ihm vor allem um sie macht er
sich so wir haben viele lodges und
unternehmen die haben im april schon
ihre leute auf unbezahlten urlaub
geschickt ja die sind jetzt erstmal zwar
nicht entlassen aber auf unbezahlten
urlaub das heißt die kriegen haben keine
einkünfte mehr und genau das wollen wir
halt von meinem gespräche mit den
mitarbeitern sind nicht einfach derzeit
stornierungen kaum neue buchungen so
lassen sich 50.000 dollar personalkosten
monatlich nicht stemmen
peter mülheim musste seinen mitarbeitern
bereits die gehälter kürzen
[Musik]
wir bitten camp manager joel kann man ja
und zu einem der masai dörfer in der
gegend zu führen auf dem weg erzählt er
dass die situation durch das geringe
gehalt nicht einfach ist für seine
familie und ihn aber anderen hier gehe
es viel schlechter
in einigen dörfern und in der ebene
haben die menschen schon hunger viele
sind weggezogen zu verwandten um ihre
familien ernähren zu können als wir in
eines der masai dörfer kommen breiten
die frauen schnell ihren schmuck
ausrichten ihre stände etwas her
in der hoffnung wir seien touristen wir
sehen wovon duell kann man ja gesprochen
hat knapp die hälfte der hütten sind
verlassen
die menschen sind zu ihren verwandten
gezogen
wir haben auch nicht genug kühe und
milch wir haben schwierigkeiten genug zu
essen zu finden
es wird immer schwieriger für die masse
nach ihren traditionen zu leben durch
die ebenen ostafrikas zu ziehen
viele sind deshalb geworden
und umso mehr angewiesen auf ihre jobs
als tourguide fahrer köche
sicherheitspersonal
wir sind unterwegs sind
naturschutzgebiet dass die masai selbst
verwalten maismehl zucker öl ausgabe von
lebensmittelrationen finanziert durch
spenden denn auch mit ihrem vieh können
die masse derzeit kaum geld verdienen um
die korona pandemie unter kontrolle zu
halten hat die regierung die vier märkte
verboten damit die menschen sich nicht
für geschäfte versammeln das ist ein
großes problem für die leute hier vor
vier jahren wurden gegründet zäune
wurden abgebaut um den wilden tieren
wieder mehr raum zu geben ohne dass die
massa so wie anderswo ihr land verlassen
ist eine safari lodge soll jobs und
einnahmen bringen nun steht sie leer was
derzeit bleibt ist die furcht vor einer
ansteckung
die menschen haben angst vor corona weil
kaum einer hier so etwas wie masken oder
selbst quarantäne vorher kannte release
dass krokus familie lebt in einer
kleinen lehmhütte im schutzgebiet ihre
mutter verkaufte schmuck an die
touristen und bekam etwas geld von dem
was die gemeinde mit den besucher
gebühreneinnahmen nun wird es immer
schwieriger den mais breit zu bezahlen
wir haben unser essen durch die
touristen verdient aber das ist vorbei
auch ranger antalya lang gas macht sich
sorgen ob er in einigen monaten noch
seine familie ernähren kann
lang gas arbeitet im sogenannten mara
triangle einem gebiet eingegrenzt von
mara fluss der tansanischen iranischen
grenze und einem bergkamm noch nie hat
er diese landschaft so leer erlebt für
die tiere sei das wie urlaub denn in
hochzeiten kämen viel zu viele besucher
sagt er und zeigt uns mehrere weibliche
löwen beim ausspähen von beutetieren die
tiere haben jetzt ihre freiheit
es gibt keine störungen
das sind keine safari autos unterwegs
die touristen kommen immer in großer
zahl zusammen um eine jagd und das
erlegen der beute zu erleben das
behindert die löwen natürlich wo sich
derzeit die nilpferde versammeln zeigt
uns lang gas eine der stellen amara
fluss wo sich schon bald die großen
herden mit zigtausenden tieren durch das
wasser kämpfen und die krokodile auf
einen guten fang lauern
immer ungefähr von juli bis september
vielleicht anfang oktober dann ist
hochsaison hier im schutzgebiet dann
bestaunen die touristen die große
wanderung und die flussüberquerung aber
wegen der cockpit 19 pandemie kommen
vielleicht gar keine besucher wenn die
safari urlauber bis dahin nicht zurück
sind wird es noch schwieriger
schon jetzt mussten die ranger ihre
patrouillen reduzieren um geld zu sparen
naja lang gas größte sorge ist dass die
wilderei wieder zunehmen könnte wenn die
menschen nicht mehr für ihr essen oder
ihre einfachen belange aufkommen könne
dann gehen sie vielleicht auf das
wildfleisch zurück in der lodge von
peter buchheim
er lebt in der hauptstadt nairobi
mehrere wochen war er nicht mehr in der
masai mara trotz krise
die liebe zu afrika bleibt was mich hier
an diesem ort fasziniert
das kann man 10
das ist einfach die weite
es ist nicht begrenzt hier die farben
wir haben jetzt gleich den sonne senkt
sich diese herrlichen farben afrika dass
man sieht und riecht
ich kann nur immer sagen es ist dann
wahnsinnig schön wieder hier zu sein das
zu sehen und gibt noch mal so einen
richtigen schub zu sagen nee das kann
man jetzt nicht einfach so den bach
runtergehen lassen
peter buchheim will weiter machen diese
verrückte zeit irgendwie überbrücken
lösungen finden
[Musik]
noch gibt es jetzt mitte mai 2020
vergleichbar wenig corona fälle in kenia
und auch peter bellheim weiß nicht ob
der große ausbruch noch kommt die folgen
der weltweiten pandemie aber sind auch
schon so in der masai mara angekommen